字幕: Mimi Uzura
校正: Emi Atarashi
皆さん こんにちは
ちょっとだけ質問します
「海」と聞いて
皆さん 何をイメージしますか？
南国のきれいなビーチを
イメージした人もいると思います
サーフィンをイメージした人も
いるかと思います
もしかしたら ジョーズのような
人食いザメをイメージして
身震いした人もいるかもしれません
夏には 私は
友人や子供と一緒にビーチを訪れ
バーベキューをしたり
海水浴を楽しんでいます
皆さんも 同じかもしれません
夏になると 釣りをする人もいます
海といえば
魚をイメージすると思います
毎日 誰かが お寿司を食べ
お刺身を食べ
魚料理を食べます
皆さんにとって
当たり前のことだと思います
もちろん 私にとっても
当たり前のことです
そんな当たり前の日常が
当たり前でない日が来ることを
みなさん ご存知でしょうか
[一人ひとりの行動が未来の海を守る]
今日は 一人一人の行動が
未来の海を守るということについて
[一人ひとりの行動が未来の海を守る]
お話ししたいと思います
未来の海を守るために
一人一人が何をするべきか？
皆さんの当たり前に ちょっとだけ
海を取り入れてほしいなと思います
私は子供の頃から
海が身近にありました
海が近くにある環境で育ち
母親は熊本市の西区
沖新町という港町で生まれ育ち
父は日本最西端の沖縄県
与那国島の出身です
そんな二人の子供である私は
幼少期から 海の近くで遊んだり
祖父母と一緒に漁港で遊んだり
祖父が漁師だったため
舟に乗って ぐるぐる
有明海を回ったりしていました
しかし 大人になって
思い出の漁港
海に行ったときに
海洋ゴミで汚れているのを目にしました
すごくショックでした
無意識だった物事に対し
意識し始めた瞬間です
ビーチクリーンをやり始めました
海をきれいにしたい
でも どんどん どんどん
ゴミがビーチに打ち上がります
何回やっても追いつきません
人の手では到底 回収できません
何とかしなければいけない
思い出のきれいな海を
取り戻したいという思いを
心の中で ずっと思っていました
そして こんなことを思いました
「陸上には清掃会社があるのに
海には清掃会社がない
なんでだろう？」と
そして私は 2019年に
未来の子供たちのために
綺麗な海を残すと決意し
国内初の海の清掃会社を
立ち上げました
「2050年問題」という言葉があります
皆さん どんな問題が起きるか
分かりますか？
ちょっとだけ考えてみてください
2050年問題 それは
海洋プラスチックゴミが
魚の総重量を上回ると
言われている年です
プラスチックゴミ 10億トン
魚の量 ８億トン
２億トンも
プラスチックゴミが多いんです
想像を絶するようです
この写真は
私が実際に撮った写真です
白いものが 発泡スチロールの破片
ペットボトルもたくさん写っています
すごくショックです 私は
皆さん これを見てどう思いますか？
実は この写真
熊本市にある漁港の写真です
近い海が こんなにも汚れています
心痛くありませんか？
［海洋ゴミの8割は街なかから］
海洋ゴミの８割は
街なかから 用水路や河川を通って
［海洋ゴミの8割は街なかから］
海に流れ出ていると言われています
特に問題なのが
マイクロプラスチックといわれる
５ミリ以下のプラスチックです
この写真は 実際に私が回収した
マイクロプラスチックです
マイクロプラスチックは
波や紫外線で劣化し 削られ
５ミリ以下になったものを言います
魚がエサと間違えて食べてしまい
最終的には 人間にまで影響を及ぼします
東京湾で釣った64匹のイワシの体の中から
マイクロプラスチックが見つかりました
海は大気中の二酸化炭素を吸収し
酸素を作るたくさんの生物がいます
街なかのゴミは
用水路や河川を通じて
海に流れ出ます
そして 紫外線や波の影響で細かくなり
５ミリ以下のマイクロプラスチックになります
それを魚がエサと間違え
食べてしまい
我々人間にまで影響を与えます
自分たちにも影響があるマイクロプラスチック
マイクロプラスチックは
有害物質を付着させやすく
魚の血液中に入り
魚全体を汚染します
それを我々人間が口にすると
免疫力の低下、子供の発達障害、代謝系疾患
発がんリスクの高まる可能性などが
あると言われています
こんなにも我々人間に影響を及ぼす海洋ゴミ
放っておけますか？
私は 何とかしたいという思いで
やってきました
放っておけませんでした
ただただ
綺麗な海を取り戻したい
それだけです
［海は誰が綺麗にしている？］
海は誰が綺麗にしてますか？
皆さん ご存じですか？
今 個人や団体で
たくさんやっている方がいらっしゃいます
そんな方々がどれだけの量を
回収していると思いますか？
海洋ゴミ問題は
皆さんに関わる問題です
回収している方は 本当に一生懸命
ゴミを回収しています
未来のためにです
でも 見て見ぬふりをする人
たくさんいます
そんな見て見ぬふりをするのであれば
未来を語る必要はありません
［他人任せが問題を深刻にし、汚染を招く］
そんな他人任せの考えが
海洋ゴミ問題を深刻にし
［他人任せが問題を深刻にし、汚染を招く］
さらなる汚染を招くんです
2050年問題 海の中は
プラスチックゴミでいっぱいになります
魚も食べられなくなる可能性があります
海水浴だって行けなくなります
子供たちをビーチに連れて行くことも
できなくなるかもしれません
そんなこと 誰も望みません
2050年は 今から27年です
27年しかありません
27年後 皆さんは
何をされているでしょうか？
もしかしたら 結婚をし
子供が生まれている方も
いらっしゃるかもしれません
お孫さんが生まれている方も
これはすごく素晴らしいことです
しかし ゴミを見て見ぬふりすると
皆さんが想像している未来との乖離を生み
自分の子供、孫に
苦しい思いをさせてしまうかもしれません
でも 私たちには出来る事があります
海洋ゴミの８割は
街なかから用水路を通って
河川を通って
海に流れていきます
８割の海洋ゴミは
あなたの身近にあるんです
それを見て見ぬふりをすると
未来の子供たち、孫が
苦しい思いをします
決して他人ごとではありません
皆さん 明るい未来を望んでるはずです
今日 こうやって私の話を聞いて
街の見方が変わると思います
皆さんには 出来る事があります
未来の子供たちのために
綺麗な海を残すために
見て見ぬふりをせず
［私達には出来る事がある］
１つでもいい
ゴミを拾う
その勇気と行動が
あなたの子供 そしてあなたの孫の
未来を明るくします
ご清聴 ありがとうございました
（拍手）